a standoff in the belgian capital on the
sidelines of a kovid 19 protest
police used water cannon against a group
of protesters
some of whom appeared to throw fireworks
several hundred people marched through
the streets two days after the
government tightened restrictions for
the third week in a row
some carried signs critical of vaccines
which have proved to be highly effective
against the coronavirus
others were worried about belgium making
it compulsory for health workers to be
vaccinated something that's coming in on
the 1st of january
i don't agree with mandatory vaccination
for nurses
i think every person has the choice to
take a vaccine
that's his own choice
and that's freedom in my opinion
health workers will have three months to
get their shots they can work during
that time if they can show they've
already had kovid 19 or provide negative
tests hospital admissions have risen by
4 week on week but the government says
40 of belgium's intensive care beds are
currently filled by covid19 patients and
that's having an impact on things like
cancer treatments
kindergartens and primary schools will
now close a week early for christmas and
pupils aged six or over have to wear
face masks
indoor venues such as cinemas will be
limited to 200 people from monday
nightclubs have already been closed and
bars and restaurants have to shut at 11
pm for three weeks nadeem baba al
jazeera